there is no single character that
represents one piece as well as the man
the woman the myth the legend bon credit
no matter what we thought upon our first
impressions in alabasta there isn't a
one-piece fan out there that didn't fall
in love with bentham slash mr twobon
cray a character with seemingly as many
names as he has faces at least i can't
comprehend someone seeing bentham's
multiple heroic sacrifices not shedding
a single tear over the true power of
friendship that he enveloped so so well
because you see bonker
is
one piece the series not the treasure of
course that would be the plot was to end
all plot twists now what we should say
is that bentham embodies what one piece
is really all about as a series so today
we're going to talk about the trois
three ways that this character
demonstrates some of the story's most
important traits and themes first
bentham is a really wacky character who
delivers a huge emotional impact if
there are two barriers of entry for new
one-piece readers it's the series length
and oda's art style however while one
thousand chapters seems very daunting at
first once readers are actually caught
up and get into the flow they'll learn
the truth one piece is
not too long it's actually too short and
away but if you're watching this channel
you probably already know that what we
should talk about instead is the other
complaint we might hear from people
hesitant to come aboard this voyage
oda's art style compared to edgier
darker looking shonen like bleach or
naruto or james tyson one piece looks
positively cartoonish sometimes in fact
ichiro ora's character designs look
rather unique within the world of mong
as a whole he has a style all of his own
that looks more bucks bunny than it does
berserk now people are often initially
put off by this art style claiming it
looks too silly or unserious but what
these readers don't really realize is
that this silliness is one of one
piece's greatest strength one piece is
silly it's goofy and ridiculous it's
genuinely funny and will make you laugh
out loud again and again but one of the
beautiful things about that comic tone
is that it makes the deeper emotional
beats hit just that much harder i think
the humor disarms us we let our guard
down then because they're initially just
along for a silly pirate adventure the
audience is reduced to tears when we
learn that our crewmates have the
saddest backstory known to men bluenosed
reindeer he will make you cry this
speedo wearing cyborg he will make you
cry the skeleton with an afro yes even
he will make you cry and so bentham
functions as a perfect maybe the most
perfect example for this phenomenon when
we first meet bonchan it's as mr
tubonkure an agent of crocodile's
baroque work organization by the way
while i was researching this video i
learned something now how i feel like i
should have known all along even though
we often refer to bentham as one clay as
if that were the name it turns out that
bonkure actually refers to a specific
night during the japanese obon festival
so whereas most of the baroque works
agents feature male and female pairs
with the man being named after a number
and a woman named after a holiday for
instance mr three and miss golden week
or mr four and miss merry christmas
bentham on the other way being
genderfluid has both code names mr tu
bon kudai surprisingly progressive for
sir crocodile or not very surprising at
all if we accept the croco mom theory
and so as a quick note for the rest of
the video i'll be using he him pronouns
for bentham because those are what are
being used in the manga and the anime
but it's important to note that the
character himself has referred to him as
a man and a woman back to how bentham
exemplifies a wacky character with
hard-hitting emotional impacts when we
first meet mr tube the audience is
struck by possibly the most ridiculous
character design in the series up to
this point he's a drowning ballerina
adorned with massive two shaped swans
and makeup job worse than that of
buggies especially in the anime the
over-the-top drama in every one of his
lines is masterfully performed by the
voice actor kazukiao a performer whose
energy is so unmatched he would
eventually be welcomed into the crew
properly as the voice of frankie he's
relegated to such a position of comic
relief all throughout the scene and the
remain of alabasta that we can hardly
see it coming when in the end of this
arc he disguises himself and his crew as
the straw hats so the real straw hats
can evade capture by the marines all
along mr two has been espousing the
power of true friendship in an
exaggerated melodramatic manner but
suddenly when the crew's livelihood is
on the line it's bentham who put his
money where his mouth is in a moment of
complete and selfless sacrifice for his
friends and so seeing such a goofy
character deliver one of the most
powerful emotional moments of the show
is one of the touchstones of one piece
and boncore is emblematic of this
feature secondly bon clay is
representative of one of one piece's
most central themes there's a really
good reason that so many western fans
know the words nakama that means
companion or friends during bentham's
first meeting with the straw hats they
become fast friends mr two and his
entertaining copy ability mesmerizes the
more immature crewmates luffy chopper
and usual in fact all of them slot in so
well with each other that they
immediately become lifelong friends as
he declares however once the crew
realized that bentham was in fact an
agent of baroque works who now possessed
the ability to change into any of the
crewmates at will the straw hats devised
a countermeasure against this technique
they drew axes on their wrists and then
covered them by tying a bandage around
the eggs however what at first was a
clever way to defend against mr two's
devil fruit powers set the groundworks
for one of the most emotional moments of
the alabaster saga these axes allowed
for their silent goodbye to vivi while
they couldn't risk revealing their close
connection to the princess to the
marines raising these marks into the air
allowed them to demonstrate their bonds
to one another signifying their undying
friendship just before this when the
marines are in heavy pursuit of the
straw hats they're just able to escape
black cage hina when mr two disguises
his ship and crew as the straw hats
acting as decoys and even though sailing
to meet vivi at the rendezvous point
will put them directly into the path of
the marines bonkers sacrifices himself
and his crew in order to give them the
chance to say farewell to their friends
they go to prison for that bonkle has a
power that seems inherently deceitful he
uses it to impersonate nifatari cobra
and kick off a war in alabasta as part
of crocodile's plan posing as someone
else has its roots in trickery and
cheating we do see this especially in
its former user higurasi who used it to
fool odin into thinking momonosuke was
in danger allowing kaido to make the
finishing blow in their battle however
in bentham's sacrifice we see the nature
of the fruit completely subverted into
something truly positive and beautiful
he's still using the money money no me
to trick someone in this case hina but
for the greater good of allowing his
friends to continue their adventure in
fact mr 2 bon kurei is one of the first
of luffy's enemies who's turned into a
true friend as miha correctly remarked
at marineford luffy's most dangerous
ability is turning those around him into
allies in in pulldown the second arc to
heavily feature bentham this trait of
luffy is even more exemplified what
began in alabaster with mr2 rallying to
luffy's eight became an entire ragtag
crew of luffy's former enemies becoming
invaluable allies heck even bonkers
former employer crocodile would join
luffy's side in the paramount war and
once again bentham would make an
ultimate sacrifice for the sake of
friendship allowing everyone to escape
the impenetrable prison of impul down so
he would have to stay behind you know
what speaking of crocodile he has a
bounty of 81 million berries since i
have around 580 000 subscribers if we
converted that into dollars and then
converted those into berries yen i would
have a 59 million very bouncy making me
significantly less dangerous than this
slimy man right here so please help me
change that by subscribing to the
channel and raising my bouncy the third
and final way that bon kure embodies the
theme of one piece is by representing
the absolute freedom that luffy seeks to
bring to the world if there is just one
theme that echoes throughout the series
even more powerfully than that of
friendship is the theme of freedom luffy
wants to become the pirate king the
person with the most freedom on the sea
nearly every island that the straw hats
travel to they restore freedom to the
citizens just like joy boy before him
luffy's heart beats in time with the
drums of liberation and so i think it's
very fitting that the okama way that mr
two embodies is also in a way the way of
freedom in bentham's great sacrifice at
impildown he grants the prisoners who
allied with luffy freedom from the
prison however he also represents this
theme to the core of his very being as
an okama honestly it was a real joy
revisiting all these bonkers moments in
the manga this is the real japanese
version by the way which is really nice
to have even if you don't speak japanese
actually have a bunch of one-piece stuff
like this official color spread behind
me that you can only get in japan which
is too bad if you don't live here
especially since it doesn't look like
you'll be able to travel to japan this
year but don't worry because that is
where today's sponsor comes in zen
market a japanese company that enables
you to purchase any japan exclusive item
and ship it worldwide to wherever you
live for just 300 yen per item which is
roughly a bit over two bucks for example
you can buy stuff from the pokemon
center from bandai or most importantly
one piece things you can even bid on
yahoo auction listings here in japan as
well i actually used just that to try
and get the limited sanji lighter in
case you know about that but that's a
story for a video in itself you do get
native customer support in over 50
languages and a variety of payment
options a link in the description below
it's no coincidence that emporio ivankov
and the kamabaka kingdom are aligned
with the revolutionary army monkey d
dragon opposes the authoritarian rule of
the world government and the celestial
dragons and so with him side by side
opposing this fascist force are
representatives of all the oppressed
people all around the one piece worlds
bartholomew kuma who literally had his
agency stripped away to become a slave
to the celestial dragons the fishman
hawk and koala representing the
fishermen who are relegated to live
beneath the red line away from the
sunlight of the surface and emporio
ivankov ruler of the okama the lgbtq
community of the one piece worlds in our
real world queer communities have fought
long and hard for decades against brutal
discrimination in order to be free to
express themselves and be able to love
and be who they are and who they love
and it's the same in one piece for
figures like ivankov who allies himself
with the revolutionary army which like
come on sanji you clearly have some
internalized prejudices you need to work
on like dude you literally got a power
up out of this from the moment we meet
bentham he's unabashedly who he wants to
be he puts no limits on his
self-expression he dresses the way he
wants to he applies makeup the way he
wants to even if not very skilled he
identifies fluidly with the gender that
he wants to his clone clone fruit even
lets him literally become whoever he
wants to be this absolute freedom of
expression is an extension of the very
same freedom that luffy is fighting for
to bring to the world one of the central
goals and themes of the entire story and
now remaining in impale down bonchan is
the new queen of newcomer land as he
says during his sacrifice in alabasta
one may stray from the path of a man one
may stray from the path of a woman but
there is no strength from the path of
humanity that is the okama way or maybe
ivankov has already come to break him
out with the help of luffy's father and
if you want to learn more about monkey
dragon and who he truly is you really
can't skip this video right here